i have to protect myself i have to go to  court on friday and actually be  questioned about something i've never  been charged with and something i was  completely against and so this is how  far it's going these leftists these  progressives who would rather want  they'd rather have the judge or  bureaucrats making decisions instead of  voters they want to hand that over to  them and not let the people in my  district  even have the right to vote for me but  no the republican party now that's a  very dishonest argument because this is  sort of like saying hey you know um  there's rules about who can be in the  house and senate and for example if a  member of the house were convicted of a  crime and then forced to resign  anybody could get up there and say you  know what  the right of the people to just decide  given that this individual was convicted  of a crime do we still want them  representing us or not that's being  denied to them right but these are the  rules